should expect everything not necessarily
through the government it's not only the
government are not only not the only
player in this region you have different
parties we are different factions you
have different ideology you have
everything in this region now the first
question that they should ask themselves
what do walls give America since Vietnam
is now nothing no political gain no
economic gain no good reputation the
United States is at all load time the
credibility that although all-time low
so before is against the interest of the
United States you know he presented his
confidence and he presented his
conviction it's not about it's not about
confidence
it's about evidence the United sorry the
Russians have completely opposite
evidence that the missiles were thrown
from area where the rebels control that
reminds me about what Kerry said about
the big lie that Colin Powell said in
front of the world on satellite about
the WMD in Iraq before going to work in
the area where they said the government
used chemical weapons we already had
video and we only have pictures and
allegations were not there our forces
I would believe our institutions don't
exist how can you talk about what
happened if you don't have evidence